♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY"
AND BEGIN WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT.
RUSSIAN FORCES ARE STALLED IN
THE NORTH AROUND KYIV AND IN THE
SOUTH, THE CITY OF MARIPOL FACE
SHELLING.
ONE AP REPORTER INSIDE THE CITY
DESCRIBED IT THIS WAY.
"TIME WAS MEASURED FROM ONE
SHELL TO THE NEXT WITH BOMB TO
APARTMENT BUILDINGS AND AN
ENDLESS LINE OF DEAD PEOPLE AND
DEAD CHILDREN.
ON THE RADIO, THE ONLY THING
COULD BE HEARD ON THE FOLLOWING,
CONSTANTLY REPEATED MESSAGE,
"MARIPOL IS SURROUNDED,
SURRENDER YOUR WEAPONS."
THE SITUATION IS DIRE ON THE
GROUND TONIGHT.
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS OPENED FIRE.
THIS IS VERY TERRIBLE TO WATCH,
MANY PEACEFUL PROTESTERS,
HITTING INNOCENT CITIZENS AGAIN.
10 MILLION REFUGEES OR MORE HAVE
FLED THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE NEW REPORTS OF
MERCENARIES BEING SENT TO
UKRAINE BY A PUTIN WITH ORDERS
TO ASSASSINATE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND HIS
ENTIRE FAMILY.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, VLADIMIR PUTIN
IS WAGING A BASELESS WAR OF
AGGRESSION AGAINST A SOVEREIGN
NATION.
MY POSITION ON THIS HAS BEEN
VERY CLEAR.
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
STUPID IN THE MOB AND THE MEDIA,
NO AMBIGUITY AS TO WHERE I
STAND.
NO MATTER HOW BAD THE SITUATION
BECOMES, THERE CAN NEVER BE ANY
U.S. BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND I
ALSO ADD THAT THERE CAN'T BE A
NO-FLY ZONE WHERE WE ARE IN
DIRECT COMBAT WITH RUSSIANS IN
THE AIR.
WE ARE NOT THE WORLD'S POLICE
FORCE.
WE CAN NO LONGER SEND OUR
NATIONAL TREASURE, YOUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS, OUR SONS AND
DAUGHTERS, TO FIGHT AND DIE IN A
CONVENTIONAL WAR PUSHED BY
POLITICIANS ON BOTH SIDES.
THEY ALL START OUT GUNG HO, THEY
NEVER FIGHT TO WIN THE WAR, THE
WAR GETS POLITICIZED AFTER
WHATEVER PERIOD OF TIME, AND THE
POLITICIANS SAY, NEVER MIND.
THE SOLDIERS GET PULLED OUT,
LIKE THE ISLAMIC EMIRATES OF
AFGHANISTAN.
WE END UP BACK AT SQUARE ONE
AFTER SO MUCH SACRIFICE AND
BLOODSHED AND SO MANY DEAD
AMERICANS AND SO MANY INJURED
AMERICANS.
NEVER AGAIN -- AND WE DO NEED TO
LEARN THE LESSONS FROM HISTORY.
NO MORE VIETNAMS, NO MORE
AFGHANISTANS PAID WE CAN AND
LEARN WHAT DOES WORK AND I'LL
EXPLAIN THAT IN A MINUTES.
IN SHORT, YOU GET WEAPONS AND
SUPPLIES TO OUR ALLIES.
IN THIS CASE IN UKRAINE, SO THEY
CAN FIGHT AND WIN MAKE THIS WAR
BY THEMSELVES WHERE THEY HAVE
SHOWN GREAT COURAGE, THE WILL TO
FIGHT, AND THE WILL TO DEFEAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVASION.
MY POSITION IS BASED ON TWO VERY
SPECIFIC FOREIGN POLICY
SUCCESSES.
WE SHOULD LEARN FROM THEM.
THE FIRST IS WHAT IS CALLED THE
REAGAN DOCTRINE.
HERE IS HOW RONALD REAGAN
DESCRIBED IT IN 1985.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE DECLARE TO OUR CITIZENS IN
THE WORLD, FREEDOM IS NOT THE
SOLE PREROGATIVE OF A CHOSEN
FEW, IT'S THE UNIVERSAL RIGHT OF
ALL OF GOD'S CHILDREN.
WE MUST STAND BY, ALL ARE
DEMOCRATIC ALLIES, AND WE MUST
NOT BREAK FAITH WITH THOSE
RISKING THEIR LIVES IN EVERY
COMPETENT FROM AFGHANISTAN TO
NICKEL WAWA, TO DEFY SOVIET
SUPPORTED AGGRESSION AND SECURE
OUR RIGHTS WHICH HAVE BEEN OURS
FROM BIRTH.
SUPPORT FOR FREEDOM FIGHTERS IS
SELF-DEFENSE.
>> Sean: WE AS CONSERVATIVES
BELIEVE IN NATURAL RIGHTS THAT
RIGHTS DO NOT COME FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT.
INSTEAD OF SENDING WAVES OF U.S.
GROUND FORCES TO FOREIGN LANDS
TO FIGHT LONG BLADED
CONVENTIONAL WARS, RONALD REAGAN
ARMED OUR ALLIES SO THEY COULD
FIGHT FOR THEIR OWN FREEDOM IN
THEIR OWN COUNTRIES.
HE DID THIS WITH NICARAGUA, THE
CONTRAS, AGAINST THE
SANDINISTAS, DANIEL ORTEGA.
THEY WERE FIGHTING THE SOVIETS
BACKED COMMUNISTS ARE THERE AND
HE ALSO DID IT WITH THEM HUNDRED
BEEN
TO MAKETHE WILL HUNDRED
NEVER PUT A SINGLE AMERICAN
BOOTS TO FIGHT ON THE GROUND
THERE.
INSTEAD OF COWERING IN FEAR OR
ATTEMPTING TO APPEASE THE
SOVIETS, HE STOOD UP TO THEM AT
EVERY TURN WITHOUT STARTING A
LONG CONVENTIONAL WAR.
GUESS WHAT?
IT WORKED.
THE SOVIETS WERE DEFEATED IN
AFGHANISTAN THANKS TO THE
STINGER MISSILES THAT
RONALD REAGAN PROVIDED THEN.
REAGAN KNEW THAT EVIL,
ESPECIALLY IN THE FORM OF AN
ISM, PASTOR JIM, COMMUNISM,
NAZISM, REAGAN CALLED THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION AND EVIL EMPIRE.
THAT'S WHY REAGAN SAID SUPPORT
FOR FREEDOM FIGHTERS IS
SELF-DEFENSE.
PRESIDENT REAGAN WAS RIGHT.
HIS POLICY SUCCEEDED.
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH WORK.
IN 2014 WE WITNESSED THE RISE OF
ISIS IN THE MIDDLE EAST AND IT
HAPPENED ON, THAT'S RIGHT,
JOE BIDEN AND BARACK OBAMA'S
WATCH.
THEY DID NOTHING.
NOT ONLY DID THESE TERRORISTS
TAKE OVER LARGE PORTIONS OF IRAN
AND SYRIA, ALSO RIPPED YOU UP
WITH A WAVE OF TERRORIST ATTACKS
UNTIL GENERAL DATES FROM
DONALD J. TRUMP WAS ONE ATTHE OO
HIS SECOND FOREIGN POLICY
SUCCESS, ANOTHER DOCTRINE WILL
WE LEARN FROM AND THAT IS THE
TRUMP DOCTRINE.
SHORTLY AFTER TAKING OFFICE ON
THE ISIS CALIPHATE INTO OBLIVION
BEER THE ONE THAT JOAN OBAMA
ALLOWED TO GROW THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP USED NEW
SOPHISTICATE AND AMERICAN
WEAPONRY, TECHNOLOGY, AIR POWER
IN THE FORM OF DRONES WITHOUT A
TRADITIONAL GROUND FORCE.
TRUMP PROPELLED ISIS FIGHTERS IN
THE SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME,
DEFEATED THE ENTIRE CALIPHATE.
HE FOUGHT THAT FIGHT TO WIN IN
WIN HE DID AND EVEN TOOK OUT THE
LEADER OF ISIS, AL-BAGHDADI AND
HIS ASSOCIATES.
ALSO USED AIR STRIKES TO COUNTER
SYRIA AND IRAN, INCLUDING A
DRONE STRIKE THAT SUCCESSFULLY
KILLED IRANIAN TERRORIST SOUL
'S WILL
SOULAMANI.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AL-BAGHDADI'S DEMISE RESINS
AMERICA'S VENTLESS PURSUIT OF
TERRORIST LEADERS AND OUR
COMMITMENT THROUGH THE ENDURING
AND TOTAL DEFEAT OF ISIS AND
OTHER TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS.
LAST NIGHT AT MY DIRECTION,
UNITED STATES MILITARY
SUCCESSFULLY EXECUTED A FLAWLESS
PRECISION STRIKE THAT KILLED
NUMBER ONE TERRORIST ANYWHERE IN
THE WORLD QASSEM SOLEIMANI.
UNDER MY LEADERSHIP FROM
AMERICA'S POLICIES, UNAMBIGUOUS
TO TERRORIST TO HARM OR INTEND
TO HARM ANY AMERICAN, WE WILL
FIND YOU, WE WILL ELIMINATE YOU,
WE WILL ALWAYS PROTECT OUR
DIPLOMATS, SERVICE MEMBERS,
ALL-AMERICANS, AND OUR ALLIES.
>> Sean: NO BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND AMERICAN VICTORY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOCTRINE WAS
VERY, VERY STRATEGIC AND VERY
EFFECTIVE.
AND IT WORKED.
IT SENT A MESSAGE OF STRENGTH TO
THE REST OF THE WORLD AND ALL
THE OTHER DESK BIDS AND
DICTATORS AND ALL OF THOSE THAT
HAVE TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS OF
THEIR OWN.
THE U.S. CANNOT USE ITS AIR
POWER UKRAINE.
PUTIN IS A MUCH DIFFERENT ENEMY
FROM AL-BAGHDADI OR SOLEIMANI.
AGGRESSIONS FROM HOSTILE ACTORS
WILL ONLY GET WORSE UNTIL THE
STOPS AND RIGHT NOW THAT'S FAR
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE ARE BRAVELY
UPENDING TERRITORIAL EXPANSION.
ESPECIALLY NATO MEMBERS IS
GREATLY DIMINISHED AND PEAS CAN
RETURN TO CONTINENTAL EUROPE
WITHOUT A CATASTROPHIC WORLD WAR
BEAR THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
TO YOU A SUPPLY UKRAINE WITH THE
WEAPONS AND THE SUPPLIES THEY
NEED TO FIGHT THEIR WAR AND
BRING VLADIMIR TO HIS KNEES, THE
WAY THAT REAGAN HAD SUPPLIED
THEM THEY'LL MAKE THEM WILL THE
GENE
WE GETTING
ACCUSING ME, SAYING"HANNITY IS N
PROPAGANDA AND SUPPORTING
VLADIMIR PUTIN."
NOT REALLY, BECAUSE I WENT OUT
ON A LIMB AND I TOLD THE TRUTH
AND I'VE BEEN SAYING BEFORE THE
ELECTION IN 2020.
JOE BIDEN IS WEAK, HE'S FRAIL, A
COGNITIVE RACK AND EVERYBODY
KNOWS IT.
EVERY POLL, OUR FRIENDS SEE IT
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE WORLD
HOSTILE ACTORS AND HOSTILE
REGIMES SEE IT ALSO.
THE LAST TWO YEARS I POINTED
THIS OUT, WELL BEFORE THE" DELL
MAKE INVASION OF UKRAINE.
WARNING THAT THE MENTAL WEAKNESS
WILL HAVE SERIOUS RAMIFICATIONS
ACROSS THE GLOBE.
TAKE A LOOK.
JOE, LET'S BE HONEST, NOT
PARTICULARLY A SMART OR BRIGHT
GUY.
BUT WHAT YOU ARE SEEING SADLY
FOR HIM IS A HOLLOW SHELL OF HIS
FORMER SELF.
A TOTAL AND COMPLETE COGNITIVE
MASS.
WHAT'S REALLY SAD IS THE REALITY
THAT IF WE CAN ALL SEE IT, SO
CAN AMERICA'S ENEMIES AND WE
HAVE REAL ENEMIES IN IRAN,
CHINA, NORTH KOREA, RUSSIA.
VLADIMIR PUTIN DOESN'T RESPECT
OR FEAR JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE SMELLING BLOOD IN THE
WATER.
WE SEE RUSSIA FULLY INVOLVED
THREATENING TO INVADE UKRAINE.
THEY ARE NOT UP TO THIS JOB.
AMERICA'S ENEMIES ARE ALSO
SEEING EVERYTHING WE ARE SEEING.
SADLY AS A RESULT, THE WORLD IN
OUR COUNTRY IS LESS SAFE AND
IT'S LESS SECURE.
UNFORTUNATELY I WAS RIGHT BUT
RUSSIA INVADED UKRAINE BECAUSE
PUTIN DID NOT RESPECT JOE BIDEN
ESPECIALLY AFTER HIS DEBACLE IN
THE ISLAMIC AMORITES OF
AFGHANISTAN.
IF YOU'RE KEEPING TRACK LIKE WE
ARE, IT'S DAY 219 SINCE
JOE BIDEN ABANDON OUR FELLOW
AMERICANS BEHIND AMERICAN LINES.
BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN IS SO
CLEARLY NOT UP TO THE JOB WITH
EACH PASSING DAY, IT JUST GETS
WORSE AND WORSE AND WORSE AND I
WISH I WAS WRONG BUT I'M NOT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FIRST LADY'S HUSBAND
CONTRACTED COVID.
LOOK IN ON THIS ROOM.
YOU CAN JUST SEE.
THAT'S RIGHT.
SHE'S FINE.
IT'S ME THAT'S NOT TOGETHER.
THE FIRST GENTLEMAN...
FOR A MOM TO A KID TO DO THEIR
HOMEWORK TO PULL INTO A
McDONALD'S PARKING LOT?
FOR REAL!
TH